we're eating each other in the U.S
internally a third of Republicans and
Democrats see members of the other party
as their mortal enemy 25 of America is
comfortable with an autocrat as long as
the autocrat represents his or her
ideals 54 percent of Democrats are
worried that their kid is going to marry
a Republican and so the fastest way to
defeat an enemy is atomize them
in the 1950s a young person had a 90
chance of out owning their parents now
it's a 50 chance only half of
Millennials are earning more than its
parents since 1989 people under the age
of 40 have seen their share of the
nation's wealth plummet from 19 to 9 and
for the first time in U.S history young
people are no longer better off
economically than their parents were at
the same age
nice positive headlines to get us
started today where did you learn that
well like um first I was great to be
with you buddy where you mentioned that
for the first time in our nation's
history a 30 year old man or woman isn't
doing as well as his or her parents
that's kind of a great breakdown in what
is the fundamental compact between a
society and its populace and that is if
you play by the rules and you're a good
person and you work hard your kids will
do better than you it's kind of what you
want anyone who has kids knows you're
only as least happy as your least happy
kid and if your kids on average aren't
doing as well as you it means to have
kids in a nation means your life is
going to go is going to the quality of
your life is going to degrade
emotionally and psychologically which
means Society no longer works for you
and it and we gotta hope it's temporary
but that's the bad news the good news is
hang on how you look at it this is a
problem of our own making you mentioned
that the wealth of people under the age
of 40 as registered by the percentage of
UDP has been cut in half
and there's this illusion of complexity
that the incumbents
will try and foment among media and the
populace to explain why these very
intractable problems are intractable and
they're not
when we the two biggest tax deductions
in America that we have passed and we
have decided make sense are mortgage
interest and capital gains who owns home
and own stocks people my age and older
who rents and makes their money working
people your age and younger so we've
effectively decided that the two biggest
tax cuts to further enrich the
wealthiest generation in history and
that is U.S Baby Boomers if we look at
the biggest transfer of wealth that's
recurring in the world it's a transfer
of wealth of one and a half trillion
dollars in people of working age
in the United States to people of
retirement age in the form of Social
Security and again that cohort receiving
a trillion and a half dollar transfer
payment from young people are the
wealthiest cohort in the history of the
planet
so education skyrocketing a regressive
tax I mean you can just go on and on and
on this isn't an accident this isn't
forces greater than us these are
deliberate decisions mostly because old
people vote mostly because presidential
politics start in Iowa and Maine the two
oldest widest states in the nation and
what do you know we have a society that
tilts Capital away from your generation
to mine and it is uh it's it's dumb it's
short-sighted and it's also morally
corrupt uh and there's it just goes on
and on and on education when I applied
to school in the 80s to college
the admissions rate was 76 the tuition
was 1200 a year that same school
the admissions rate is six percent and
the tuition is closer to thirty thousand
a year
so everything we've done has sort of
stacked the deck it's sort of baby
boomers have decided heads I win tails
you lose
did the Baby Boomers overachieve or are
millennials and Zoomers underachieving
or is it a combination of the two you've
said that they were the wealthiest ever
did they get a disproportionate gain
during that period the Boomers
so I think a lot of people will try and
create this Trope of The Quiet quitting
expectant lazy Millennial or gen Z and I
don't think there's any evidence of that
I I think that you could argue them more
socially conscious I think work from
home probably creates
uh more temptation to spend more time
with your dogs and maybe working all the
time but
the kids and this is there's some
proximity bias here the kids that come
out of my class at NYU the kids I work
with at property media
are more impressive every year and they
work very hard
what has changed is that things housing
is more expensive for them schooling is
more expensive for them and a lot of
their taxes have gone up and my life has
gotten easier as I've gotten older so I
don't
uh in terms of the baby members I don't
think have outperformed I think they've
been fairly lucky they came of age
during the greatest economic boom of
History
um you know the last basically last 13
years have been incredible in the last
40 have been pretty pretty remarkable in
terms of prosperity but what the baby
members have done have done a great job
of
is ensuring that when there's a pandemic
and we need massive massive relief it
doesn't go to poor or young people it
goes to older wealthy people
two-thirds of the PPP program ended up
in the top quintile of household income
earners
so we've basically done a great job of
kind of weaponizing governments and
creating what I call this really
dangerous rejectionist exclusionary
Society where it's once I have a college
degree
I'm going to encourage my University to
pull up the gates and applaud the dean
when admissions rates go down and the
university rankings love this
exclusionary
kind of luxury brand positioning once I
have a house once I buy a house I find
the money to get a house I try and make
it more difficult for other houses to be
built I show up to local board meetings
and Community meetings and I make it
difficult to approve any additional
housing once I have a tech company
that's working I spend more and more
money on lobbying to ensure that I can
abuse My Monopoly position and ensure
small companies don't get out of the
crib so it's this rejectionist
exclusionary culture
that has emerged that's turned America
or morphed America from what was the
best place to get rich into the best
place to stay Rich there's very little
churn here most of the pandemic programs
if you think about it were some loaves
of bread and circuses thrown for the
poor all creating cloud cover around the
majority of the capital ended up in the
market which shot asset prices up 90 of
stocks our own and 90 of real estate by
Dollar volumes owned by the top one
percent
it was really just cloud cover to ensure
that Nana and Pop-Pop could upgrade
their Cruise cabins
and uh so I I think these are deliberate
this is the bad news we've deliberately
taken money from young people and
transferred it to old people the good
news is that if we can make it happen we
can unmake it all of these problems are
solvable
give me your thoughts on Tick Tock I
know that you dug into some of the
research around that the way that it's
been weaponized and also the impact that
it's having on young people
so let me just start off by saying I
love Tick Tock
um I think it's an extraordinary product
I think it was genius to take a platform
and say it shouldn't be social it's not
about what your friends think about you
it's not about choices it's not about
finding anything you want like YouTube
it's not about
you know feeling bad about yourself
because you don't have a six-pack or
you're not as rich as your friends on
Instagram
it's about a streaming media platform
where there's no choice you have one
choice you you tap the logo and it
immediately starts calibrating based on
what you like what you swipe up swipe
down on and before you know it you're in
the ultimate tailored individualized
singular streaming media Network that is
just addictive it's just I could I could
go on to tick tock right now in for a
couple hours just watch it I think my 12
year old boy if he had his way would
disappear into his room with his phone
put diapers on so we could watch Tick
Tock for 72 hours straight and not have
a bathroom break I think this thing is
an amazing product
uh the issue is if I were a member of
the CCP and I saw that we had vested
interest in diminishing America's
standing strategically in the world
and that the easiest way to do that was
not with Kinetic power because we don't
have the capital that the US has to
spend on aircraft carrier fleets or even
through corporate Espionage and they do
a great job of that
I would just take my thumb and very
elegantly and insidiously put it on the
scales of content
it reflects America in a bad light so
whether you're Kim Kardashian or Joe
Rogan
for Jonathan hi a lot of your content
reflects American a very positive life
in a lot of your content highlights the
problems we have
it would be very easy I believe they're
doing this now I think they'd be stupid
not to do this and put their thumb on
the scale of content
did says our elections are being
weaponized
racism in U.S has not gotten better it's
gotten worse
that capitalism does not work that you
can't trust your leaders and slowly but
surely raise a generation of Americans
of Civic leaders military leaders
Business Leaders that feel bad about
America
and also aren't focused on the human's
rights violations in China but basically
you know if you think of geopolitics as
a horror movie
it's not it's not outside threats right
now we are stronger than we've ever been
I would argue competitively no one's
lining up for Chinese or Russian
vaccines our GDP growth hasn't matched
China's but it's more consistent the
smartest brightest hardest working
people in the world all have one thing
in common and that is they like the idea
of either getting to Europe or getting
to the United States especially so we're
the football team that gets the top
draft choices every year from every High
School in the world so we're doing
really well but the horror movie would
be that horror movie where they say the
call is coming from inside the house
we're eating each other in the U.S
internally a third of Republicans and
Democrats see the other party members of
the other party is their mortal enemy 25
percent of America is comfortable with
an autocrat as long as the autocrat
represents his or her ideals 54 percent
of Democrats are worried that their kid
is going to marry a Republican
and so the fastest way to atomize or the
fastest way to defeat an enemy is
atomize them and I think Tick Tock uh
when you have kids under the age of 18
spending more time on Tick Tock than
they spend on every streaming media
company combined would we be comfortable
with Netflix Hulu Disney Plus
um HBO Max all being owned by China and
I don't think we would so I think there
needs to be a separation between
ownership and the product I think that
meta was the ultimate Espionage product
I don't think the most out in the NSA
the gru MI6 and their Wildest Dreams
could have come up
with meta and I think we're going to
find out that our ability to take out
some of these Taliban leaders has been a
function of their niece being on
Instagram we GPS drone them
uh and I also and I realize this sounds
paranoid it doesn't mean I'm wrong I
think after the Senators and the elected
leaders in America have their photo ops
berating Mark Zuckerberg they go into a
confidential hearing and he says do you
want us to continue help killing Taliban
leaders and they say yes and he says
well back the [ __ ] off I think that's
why we haven't had any meaningful
legislation against the big American
platforms but anyways
the ultimate propaganda tools Tick Tock
I just don't I think they would be
stupid not to do this and I think we're
naive to think that they won't be able
to do it easily and I think we should I
think it presents a real National
Security risk the wild thing is that
Tick Tock content that is disintegrating
America or reducing patriotic feelings
towards it is generated by U.S in
America yeah this isn't this isn't the
Chinese creating content but because of
the dynamic of audience capture and the
reinforcement mechanism of getting that
status response
you can press your hand on the scale
that rewards creators that create a
particular type of narrative and that it
turns every individual Tick Tock user
that cares to talk about politics to be
more likely uh an unwitting unwilling
CCP agent
it's so brilliant and Insidious at the
same time and by the way let's wrap all
of this in really joyous dance videos
which makes it all feel really benign
with Justin Bieber the catastrophe and
the apocalypse will be done to a Justin
Bieber sound that's right it doesn't
really matter it all feel good and you
don't even have to put your thumb on the
scale of certain individuals and not
others it can be the content from the
same individual in this podcast
I will talk about very hopeful things
uh for America you know I don't think
there's anything wrong we can't fix we
50 of the world's philanthropy
originates from U.S institutions
yeah we if you were to have one Global
headline news headline for the last
hundred years would be that British
Russians and the Americans turn back
fascism the one headline for the last 50
years would be unprecedented Global
Prosperity led by America
I'll also talk about failing young men
in the U.S and how they're struggling
and they've never done young men have
never followed that cohort has fallen
further faster in the U.S and then in
history if you're Tick Tock and you have
a series of 30 seconds 30 second clips
and you're with a CCP
which narrative do you want to see
rolling more often
and it's just super super easy they
could just take they don't need any they
don't need to produce their own content
they just need to tweak the algorithm to
say in the same 60 Minutes an individual
will have Pro and anti-American content
and we're just going to slowly but
surely dial up the anti-American content
and it's from it's from someone you
trust it's from someone who also has
pro-american content so you think their
content is credible let's create a lot
of doubt about the efficacy of the
vaccines when there's there's thoughtful
discourse on both sides I would argue 90
plus percent of the thoughtful discourse
about vaccine says on a risk-adjusted
basis you should get a vaccine
and then 10 or less is doctors saying it
Alters your DNA
if I'm the CCP and I want to create
controversy and I want to get us hating
each other more
let's make that content 50 50. let's
have everyone go at each other
over the vaccines so I always say just
quite frankly if I were them that's what
I would do why spend money on aircraft
carriers why why compete on 11 playing
field when that when we have this Trojan
Horse
the size of Montana
residing in the U.S and we have this
vehicle that the upcoming generation of
Americans love and just a few small
tweaks and slowly but surely they won't
even know the movie The Sting I don't
know if you saw it uh with Robert
Redford and Paul Newman but the key to a
great con is the mark never knows they
were conned
we're all victims of propaganda right
now we all see on the left and on the
right that sways our view but we don't
think we've been fooled it's much easier
to fool someone than convince them
they've been fooled because to
acknowledge you've been fooled it's like
saying I acknowledge I'm an ass I'm
acknowledged someone's gotten the better
of me and people don't like that
so I think it's happening now and I
don't think we know what's even
happening to us
we also don't know what's happening in
China I don't know how much truth is
behind this but I've heard that the
Chinese algorithm on Tick Tock shows a
very different sort of world it's young
and Chinese people doing engineering and
being smart and conscientious and
admirable and patriotic
another consideration is
9.6 trillion minutes of Netflix watched
in 2021
22.6 trillion minutes of tick tock
watched in 2021
given the fact that a tick tock video at
most can be 60 Seconds
and probably the average Netflix thing
is 30 minutes
that blows my mind
it's just it's it's staggering and to
your point uh that The Tick Tock version
or the Chinese version of tick tock and
it's duyan
uh it's all aspirational look at this
kid from Shenzhen who's a concert
pianist look at the incredible research
we're doing look at these kids what
they're building in their in their high
school it's all uplifting no politics I
mean none at all
it's so this is what the Chinese have
decided they want their youth to see
could you could that not be an argument
that in China talking about the CCP in
any way that's not positive would be
difficult to do no matter how you put
your finger on the balance of the
of the platform they have a broader
structure that stops people from doing
that 100 and some people would argue
they shouldn't be our role model
but even if you take even if you take
the societal issues and the complicated
conversation around censorship and media
because whenever you hear hear the words
ban and media in the same sentence you
should understandably have a gag reflex
because I think one of the keys to a
productive Democratic Society is that
pretty much anyone can say pretty much
anything about pretty much anyone else I
do think that's super important
but
take that push that aside should Chinese
sectors and companies have unfettered
access to our markets when we have
absolutely none to theirs
yeah Twitter Google meta what's our
access over there zero
we have limited access we have just
enough access initially and they create
body language and a head fake that they
might let us be in there just long
enough so they can steal the
intellectual property they then prop up
a local entrepreneur fund that local
entrepreneur and their attitude is we
can steal the Google algorithm or create
something a reasonable facsimile and
there's probably a two or three hundred
billion dollar company
uh search engine that can just feed off
the domestic Market what do you know
it's Baidu why on Earth are we going to
go the Western Way
and go would do what Italy or South
Korea does and let our newspapers go out
of business and let all of the
shareholder value transfer to California
I mean you got to admire them from a
Chinese standpoint it's really really
meanwhile the limiting the amount of
time that their children can play video
games one hour between 8 and 9 pm Friday
Saturday Sunday per week that's it the
only way that you can play games is
through a streaming service the
streaming service just to just flick the
switch it's just not on you can't do it
meanwhile you have men that are being
given fakes Fitness cues and their
conscientiousness and desire for
aspiration and chasing goals is being
repurposed across into League of Legends
or whatever other game they're now
playing online they are able to get
uncanny vulvas from Pawn so they're
being given fake reproductive Fitness
signals from porn fake uh achievement
Fitness signals from video games this is
why so you've got a a quote that I found
very interesting so I had Richard Reeves
on the show recently of boys and men
brand new book which is out and it's
really interesting you said uh the most
dangerous person in the world is a man
who's broke talking and alone
what do you mean by that
well first off let me acknowledge I I
was I had shutters go down my spine when
I saw that my book was coming out the
same book as Richard's book I think that
guy is amazing yeah
and uh I have been feeling and seeing
this notion of how poorly young men are
doing I just can see it in my friends
with their songs I have friends who have
two daughters and a son and I'm saying
this metaphorically but Loosely speaking
the daughters of Penn the younger
daughters working at PR firm in Chicago
and the sun is in their basement vaping
and playing video games
young men
a seven to ten high school
valedictorians or girls for every one
male college graduate over the next five
years there's going to be two female
college graduates
93 of mass Shooters are men three times
more likely to overdose four times more
likely to commit suicide 12 more times
more likely to be incarcerated they do
worse in single parent households for
some reason girls have the same outcomes
in a dual parent household versus a
single we have more single parent
households our education system is
biased against men men on a
behavior-adjusted are boys on a behavior
adjusted voices are twice as likely to
get suspended for the same infraction as
a girl two-thirds to 80 percent of all
primary and secondary teachers are are
women and understandably they're going
to Champion little girls who they see
themselves in
so young men just have the deck stack
against them if you walk down the Avenue
that is America
one in three men under the age of 30
will not have had sex in the last year
and people hear the word Saxon their
brain fires different ways but sexism is
a key step to the elemental Foundation
of any society and that's a relationship
and then you you rap and covet you rap
in the biological
fact that men's pre-fertile cortex
doesn't evolve as quickly they're more
immature and then you have all this
these this kind of short form ability to
get similar dopa of relationships on
social similar dopa that you're learning
or or get or taking risks with Robinhood
or gambling you're not learning you're
not investing you're gambling and it's
fun but it's gambling you don't have to
put on a shirt or figure out the skills
to meet women because you can get some
of that hit by watching porn
I mean what's your motivation to go out
and go through the humiliation of dating
to get to your own sex when you get a
sort of a reasonable facsimile of it at
home what's your what's your rationale
for working hard and delaying
gratification when you keep keep seeing
these screenshots of men who've made
twelve thousand percent return on Solana
so and men are good at executive
functions they're kind of two years
behind an 18 year old boy applying to
college is sort of on par with a 16 or a
17 year old girl or put another way did
you see uh Paige Harden published a
study looking at the
um comparative levels of impulse control
between boys and girls so you can
imagine there's a graph over time in
terms of impulse control the time is
going along the bottom you've got two
lines that are both male and female for
a male to have the same level of impulse
control as a 10 year old girl
they need to be 24.
yeah the the Delta I've heard that's
striking the Delta I've heard is two
years but even if you think about two
years
you basically if you have two 18 year
old people applying to college
basically the 18 year old is competing
against a 16 year old
so imagine imagine you're in 10th Grade
applying to college and all the girls
are in 12th grade
that's that's what we're facing right
now and at NYU I can tell you that some
of the schools there if they were
totally applicant blind it would not
only be predominantly female they'd be
70 Asian female I mean the Asian
Community has been so successful in our
society as it as it comes to producing
traits and behaviors that colleges love
and people think well okay if if men if
men are finally not doing very well I
mean we basically we level the playing
field about an education and what we
found is women just absolutely blew by
yeah man because absolutely blew by and
you think well what's the problem with
that well when it was 40 60 female to
female to male we decided to do
something about it with Title IX and
affirmative action and we leveled up
women now that it's 40 60 or you could
even argue 3366 in terms of graduation
because men grad drop out the question
is well are we concerned now and the the
knock-on effect here is that
getting a college degree is still a
really good plan B for Economic Security
on average over the course of your
lifetime a college grad will make about
double what a non-college grad makes
and so what you have is women mate
socioeconomically horizontally and up
men horizontally and down
the bottom line is women with college
degrees aren't interested in mating with
men without college degrees
so you have this what I'll call Porsche
polygamy effect
and that is when you take the Chaser of
online dating which is doing the same
thing that technology does to every
sector is consolidating it and creating
a winner take most environment the top
10 percent of men in terms of
attractiveness on Tinder get 80 90 of
the swipe rights they get they get all
of the attention which quite frankly
doesn't lead to a lot of great Behavior
you know too much opportunity is not
necessarily a good thing the 50 to 90
percentile in terms of attractives from
men do okay in the bottom fifty percent
are just totally shut out
and what happens to these men who are
totally shut out for mating
opportunities they lose confidence they
start becoming much more prone to
misogynistic content with these internet
celebrities telling them it's not their
fault it's a woman's fault
they become less likely to believe in
climate change they become more
nationalist I mean young men are very
good at blaming other people when things
aren't going well for them and so what
are the most violent dangerous societies
all have in common they all have a
disproportionate number of the most
dangerous person on the planet a young
broken alone man and we're just
producing way too many of them and we
can't even have an honest conversation
about it because the moment you start
evangelizing for young men the moment
you're seen as quote unquote pro- young
man
the natural assumption is that means
you're
anti-women because admittedly there's
some guys out there on Tick Tock
claiming to be trying to give men
confidence
that basically it's basically thinly
veiled misogyny yes referring to women
as [ __ ] and you gotta own the [ __ ]
and you got to get out there take my
class for 49 a month and you'll get the
money and put the [ __ ] in their place
you're like Jesus Christ that's what
young men are are susceptible to it's
really it's it's dangerous and it's ugly
so I think a lot about masculinity I
think we need I think the left needs to
take back masculinity
and one of the things I enjoy doing I'll
be a podcast I'm a profane vulgar person
and for some reason profanity and
vulgarity has been completed with some
sort of non-progressive person no it's
not comedians who've been really profane
and vulgar tend to be more Progressive
masculinity is a wonderful thing it's
not necessarily the domain of
people-born men but advocating for
others protecting others using skills
and strengths to protect other people
you know being aggressive that is a
wonderful thing when when Russians come
pouring over the Border in Ukraine you
want some of that big dick energy
masculinity is a wonderful thing and it
should be embraced and to conflate
toxicity and masculinity is bad for
society and we've gotten to a point
where we don't value young men we're not
giving them as many opportunities as
we're giving older Generations much less
other young women and it's a I think
it's an existential crisis for United
States and you know who wants more
emotionally economically viable men
women
and women have a much finer filter for
mating than men
and they're just not finding that many
good young men they're just we aren't
producing enough of them it doesn't
surprise me that it's a confusing
situation to be in men are being told to
both man up and open up but to avoid
being toxically masculine but when you
see the
revealed preferences versus stated
preferences of the way that women date
that guys should get over their fear of
tall women when Zendaya and Tom Holland
got into a relationship together it's
like I I don't think that short guys
were turning down Zendaya I think that
it's the other way around on average
women want a partner that's 21
centimeters taller than them on average
men want a partner that's 16 centimeters
shorter than they are so I all of that
is something that everyone listening to
the show will be very familiar with this
mating crisis that we're seeing at the
moment is something that I've been very
passionate about
something that Richard taught me about
last week when I was on the show is
young male syndrome why have we not got
these swaths roving gangs of young
disaffected youths youth guys pushing
over granny and causing havoc and stuff
like that
that hasn't happened that that just
doesn't seem to be happening yes you've
got School shooters they are individual
groups yes the salmon Rishi thing again
as well was also an individual loan
actor probably somebody that had been
more integrated into a family and into
his local community would have been less
likely to commit that sort of an act
but we haven't seen it on mass in the
same sort of way you correct with what
you say between 2008 2018 men went from
eight percent to 28 the number of men
that haven't had sex in the last year
however
we haven't seen this proliferation of
young male syndrome occurring and
Richard's contention was that
the fake Fitness cues that you're
getting from technology are sedating men
they're repurposing some of that energy
that they would have put into being very
aggressive out into the world and as
opposed to us going out with a bang
we're going out with a fizzle
and from what I see the sort of rhetoric
that I hear online from Men
it is a lot less I'm going to go out and
do something about this it is a lot more
I'm going to retreat in to me just hold
on tight boys the sex robots are coming
soon like these are non-ironic comments
that I see on the internet so I think
this is a bit of availability bias
because it's something new that I've
just learned about so I'm all excited
about it and it seems to explain stuff
but I do think that there is a very good
argument to be made that you're not
going to end up with dangerous men
you're going to end up with the useless
man
I think that's fascinated I mean
everything you're saying I'm I'm kind of
trying to take mental notes because
the the we always go back to history
right and in early 30s Germany it looked
more like the US and we'd like to admit
it was prosperous it had a thriving LGBT
community and then when it was
economically harmed young men were doing
well they found scapegoats and you're
right they put on brown shirts and they
started you know mistreating old people
you're not you're not seeing that in the
United States what I would argue though
is that we're electing people who are
doing it in a more Insidious fashion and
that is
um there's been more women all elected
almost all elected representatives have
a college degree so to a certain extent
are elected representatives should
somewhat mimic College grads that's the
one thing they all have in common almost
all of them have went to a call went to
college
for 40 years now we've been producing
more female college graduates and male
college graduates which would lead you
to understandably believe there should
be more female electrolators the male
leaders there's not 28 percent of our
elected leaders are female
and I think it's because men and women
incorrectly conflate the tone of your
voice and your height with leadership
qualities so show me a woman who's 5'3
and has an IQ of 130 and I'll show you
School Board president
show me a guy who's six two with a full
head of hair who has 105 IQ I'll show
you a senator
and
what what you have is is a group of men
and our parties are now bifurcating and
the Democrats are representing female
college graduates
and Republicans are representing
non-college graduate males
and I think some of the red are coming
out of Washington that feels a little
bit especially on the right feels a
little bit like fascist light and you
see the Italian new Italian Prime
Minister
that it's a different type of repackaged
violence it's violence against
immigrants it's slow burn violence
against women in the form of taking
their rights back to Old Spain
so it's not as obvious as a as a gang of
young men going into the streets and
beating up on on vulnerable people I
think in some ways it's more
um more institutionalized where we elect
people who say things they don't even
believe because they know that they have
a powerful voting
group and young disaffected males
and I think they're overrepresented in
Washington actually when you look at our
if you look at the United States
we have minority Rule and that's on the
left far left and far right because of
gerrymandering but about 30 percent of
our Senators represent about five
percent of our population and those
Senators tend to represent conservative
districts and those conservative
districts are producing all of these
kind of young uneducated men who are
looking for scapegoats looking looking
for to blame immigrants
not being as concerned about climate
change not being as protective of
women's rights so I think that I think
the violence is still there it's just
being repackaged
but to your point
just as cancer was an epidemic that we
finally started talking about not an
epidemic but it was closeted and we had
open conversations about that and made
it normalized it to talk about it and
made huge progress against it because we
normalized the conversation we're going
through the same thing with mental
illness people are openly talking about
their own mental illness challenges and
it's a wonderful thing and it'll help
normalize it and address it I think that
the next thing that's going to come out
of the closet is the crisis and
loneliness
and that is I think so many people
Boy Scout and Girl Scout enrollment is
way down the percentage of people talk
to their neighbors is way down the
percentage of people playing an athletic
league play sports see their friends
every day have a good friend the number
of people who say they have a good
friend is to climb by a third in the
last 10 years the number of kids who see
their friends every day has been cut in
half of the last 10 years
and it shows that loneliness raises your
blood pressure increases the likelihood
you'll have a stroke increases the
likelihood of depression and for young
men especially it's important because if
you don't have friends
if you have a girlfriend I joined a
fraternity when I was 17 years old
exactly 40 years ago this week I rushed
a fraternity at UCLA and there's a
cartoon of fraternities and there's a
lot of bad things about them I would
encourage any young man to join a
fraternity if he goes to college because
it took a 30 000 foot 30 000 person
community and it it shrank it down to
something manageable for me and I
remember my roommate saying stop smoking
so much pot I remember my roommate
saying you know oh you're you're on crew
or you want to row for crew I had other
male role models the difference between
a 22 year old male who I was friends
with a Nathan was huge and there were
men young men on the crew team at 22. I
wanted a bro crew and so they mentored
me and worked out with me and you know
and I got much more fit I needed that
socialization I needed those guardrails
I needed other men to tell me to get my
[ __ ] together I didn't grow up with
siblings my father wasn't around
young men there are now neighborhoods
where there are no men
I mean just none especially in black
neighborhoods because of incarceration
rates in male abandonment
and what's really interesting is I think
we should think about really
unconventional experiments in New York
and New Jersey because of covid we have
big prison relief programs because kova
just ripped through the prisons because
most of these prisoners had not been
exposed to any novel coronaviruses or
coronaviruses so they just were it just
ripped through so they had a prison
release program and what they found was
the communities that absorbed the most
men from a prison release program crime
went down
because what they found is in general
these men would speak to younger men and
say don't [ __ ] up like I did
and so this absence of men this absence
of male role models the moment a kid
doesn't have a boy doesn't have a male
role model in his life he becomes
immediately twice as likely to be
incarcerated
so this this numbing of America this
loneliness epidemic and this lack of
male role models I think is a big deal
but I I love the way it's really
interesting I want to do more research
on what you just said that they're not
as external a big a threat they're more
of a threat to themselves and you're
right it may be just that they're more
dangerous to themselves than to others
yeah I mean so much to go through the I
think
one of the interesting things when it
comes to controlling uh reproductive
Independence for women it seems like
women are mostly the enactors of control
when it comes to that if it was left up
to men women's abortion rights would
have almost certainly not been touched
based on a bunch of polling that I've
seen that might be interesting for you
to look at if you've not seen it before
as well
um a ton of polls seem to suggest that
men are less enforcing when it comes to
this than women are that women tend to
be the people that are voting pro-life
as opposed to pro-choice that was
something surprising that I learned
about but yeah I mean
all of this together is a very messy
situation in a
maladapted uh an evolutionary mismatched
world
filled with novel technology that can
not only propagate ideas but allows
people who don't have worth of status to
gain status it's it's a real a real sort
of blending dangerous blender of a lot
of Novel stimulus that no one really
understands how to deal with
one thing that we maybe previously would
have had would have been commentators
that we trusted coming through
mainstream media and I know that you
looked at what makes a story go viral
and why pundits suck nowadays I think
this is a little bit more prevalent in
the US than it is in the UK I'm not
saying that the BBC or ITV are
completely impartial or Sky News or
anything else like that
I do get the sense that they're a little
bit more about news than about opinion
so why aren't pundits stepping in and
being the appropriate Gatekeepers
between reality and cultural
Consciousness that they should be
because there's no money in it and I
just moved to London and my initial
observation granted I'm gonna everything
uh British is charming a novel for me
right now I'm right I have an accent in
you what I find is like I believe in a
nationalized healthcare system that also
has a private layer I I think in a
Democratic or a capitalist Society we
have to acknowledge that rich people are
gonna have better lives and I think
that's the basis of capitalism that
we're going to have billionaires and
people wanting to be one of those people
is a huge motivator
and so I think a nationalized system
that has a certain Baseline level a
pretty good level of Health Care and
then a private label that emerges above
it is actually a pretty decent system
and people will get upset about the
inequity but let's have a longer
conversation about the inequities of
capitalism it's the least like I believe
what Churchill said it's the least bad
the worst system of its kind except for
all the others I think the same is true
of media
uh the BBC wouldn't survive I don't
think if it was for-profit I think if
you're gonna have straight down the
middle just the facts ma'am it's not as
entertaining
it's harder to keep people engaged it's
a good brand positioning but the reason
why CNN and fox went to either end of
the poll is that it's just more
entertaining in the 70s in the US we
used to have the the news used to be a
public service of of networks that were
making so much money running commercials
Against The Brady Bunch or the A-Team or
Love Boat they said 30 minutes a night
we're gonna tell you what's going on and
it's going to be nine minutes of
commercials 18 minutes of news and three
minutes of opinion and there was this
great skit based on that opinion on
Saturday Night Live where basically Dan
Aykroyd would call Jane Curtin an
ignorant slot that was the opinion
section and they'd go at it
and then slowly but surely Ted Turner
and Rupert Murdoch realized that they
should flip it have three minutes of
actual news and 18 minutes of opinion
and reinforce people's tribal beliefs
and get angry and go after the other
side and it's really entertaining and we
have this situation room like a headline
or a Chiron that says things slightly
better today globally doesn't sell
so we've kind of catastrophized the
world and when there are increasing gas
prices 71 to 73 days there's 21 New York
Times headlines when of 80 of the last
85 days gasoline prices have declined
there's one headline
and so we've started
you know CNN and fox go to the left go
way to the left and way to the right so
I think having government I think the
only way you have what I'd call
non-partial or an attempt to have some
sort of non-partial news driven I think
it's got to have government support
because it's not entertaining and it
doesn't get the eyeballs
um uh so I'm a big fan of the BBC I'm a
big fan of government supported news and
media I think also social media needs
more identity verification because I
think that actors weaponize
misinformation and I think we also need
section 230 carve out such that if you
spread misinformation around vaccines or
elections just as we've done around
trafficking you have the same liability
that this show has or the traditional
media has but pundits don't step into
The Fray because the really the ones
that are really trusted
can make 10 million dollars a year
being partisan and their capitalist too
so you could they go to uh PBS and be
more neutral yeah could they go to the
BBC and being more neutral I'm doing a
show on BBC I just signed up I'm doing a
show congratulations I like it thank you
I'm really excited about it and I did it
because everything the BBC does just
kind of wreaks equality and production
values I also like the fact that they
will fact check everything to death
everything to death
and they will do their best
to to you know to call balls and Strikes
I'm not making as much money there as
when I worked at CNN
there's just not as much money in it and
so I like it I feel good about it but
I'm in a position to do it and when
other people get offered big money to do
something for Fox or CNN yeah you can't
blame them well you get a tragedy at the
commons effect a little bit here right
that by you taking the high roads that
leaves a spot at CNN open for somebody
else so by you curtailing your ability
to make money notes that you don't
perhaps need to make so much money
anymore but I went to a broadcasting
house about four weeks ago I was back in
the UK for a while and I got to go to
broadcasting house I don't know whether
you've been there yet but the even the
atmosphere inside of that place there's
a proper Newsroom out the back and it's
behind where they filmed the six o'clock
news on an evening time you can see
everyone screwing around writing bits
and pieces apparently the uh gentleman
that I was there with that was
interviewing me told me that during Hugh
Edwards announcement of the Queen's
passing like the main one that's going
to be used for the next Century for when
the queen passed two of the workers that
were in The Newsroom behind were taking
photos on their phone or some Instagram
story so Hugh Edwards is doing this
really serious thing and in the
background there's two people taking a
video of it who apparently were
reprimanded very quickly and and given a
very big slap on the wrist
I was thinking there about this um
way that competition for eyeballs has
evaporated some of the
um other more higher quality elements
that came about in news programming and
there's this thought experiment that I
learned about years ago to do with rats
living on an island so there's a hundred
rats living on the Island the island has
a carrying capacity of a thousand rats
these hundred rats are spending their
time they're doing art and poetry
obviously very smart rats art and poetry
and playing Sport and making love and
and finding food and stuff but they
don't need to compete that much for food
or for finding love because there's tons
of spec carrying capacity now over time
as the population begins to grow and
grow and grow you find that the rats who
focus more on survival and reproduction
and less on the Superfluous things that
add color but doesn't actually add a
reproductive benefit or a competitive
benefit if it was in a commercial Market
they end up being more successful
which selects the survivors yeah which
selects over time more and more and more
and then after you reach full carrying
capacity once you hit that 1000 Mark any
Rat that decides that he or she wants to
try and do art or culture or poetry or
whatever it is they're immediately
competed out of the gene pool or
defeated in the market of ideas or the
market of attention and eyes because
they're unable to compete with the
people that are chasing the only thing
that really really matters in terms of
survival and reproduction I kind of see
something similar here that it does
become a race to the bottom of the brain
stem if you if you decide to do
less partisan talking points if you
decide to talk about more positive news
stories if you decide to be more
balanced in your approach to things if
that loses the amount of attention you
get where's that attention going to go
well it's going to go to somewhere else
that does decide to put that sort of
rhetoric across so you have to play this
game or else you become one of the rats
that's competed out of the gene pool
yeah there's a lot there I'm not
familiar with that let's study but the
notion of I'll equate survival
techniques with grit and there there's a
ton of studies showing that intelligence
does dictate success but tops out at
about 110 IQ so smart people are more
likely to be wealthy and successful than
dumb people but really smart people are
no more likely than smart people the
Delta is perseverance and grit so
survival mentality
the reason I'm wealthy is because I
didn't have a lot
I'm very talented but
um if I had I say this a lot if if I had
what my kids have now I wouldn't have
what I have now yeah if I were my sons
and this is my struggle the only two
things I knew I would have as an adult
male would be a Range Rover and a
cocaine habit
I'm just not that I would I wanted money
and I didn't have any and I was smart
enough to look around in America and go
the difference between having Better
Health Care Living in a nicer Place
having a broader selection set of mates
is money yep and so and and for me it
became very apparent very early because
my mom got very sick and I just saw U.S
health care is really a caste system
when it comes to
when it comes to money and I I decided
very early and people don't talk about
this or they don't they don't like to
admit it
I was I had a monocular focus on it
that's it I was like oh I don't want to
meet a great woman or I want to change
the world or I want to help car climate
change no no I'm gonna be [ __ ] Rich
that was that was my decision as a
younger man and I want to be clear it's
not a decision it's not something
entirely in your control I had a lot of
wins in my back but it was a sole focus
of mine and I also coach young men
take economic responsibility for your
household and sometimes that means
getting out of the way and being more
supportive of your spouse or partner
who's better at this whole money thing
than you that's also being a man but a
good place to start as a young man is
you need to take economic responsibility
for your household that means figuring
out a way that at some point you might
be able to help your parents figure out
a way that you're economically viable
figure out a way that you can have the
money such you have a very stressful
life if you have decide to have a family
so I like the grid component
I think the problem is the opposite I
don't think the island runs out of
bananas and food and only the
survivalists I think the problem is
actually the opposite and that is we
live in an era of super abundance and
that is our technology is so
extraordinary at taking the same amount
of inputs and producing so much more
that our instincts haven't caught up to
institutional production of sugar fat
um entertainment porn we're just we
don't know how to modulate these things
because when we saw red meat when we saw
sugary salty snacks just a few
Generations ago it was like [ __ ] eat it
all because you don't know where your
next meal is coming from
and so the the fact that we get all of
the super abundance now
results and externalities and anytime
you take one commodity and turn it into
something much more valuable whether
it's oil into petroleum whether it's
attention into money there's
externalities there's been enormous
externalities from the refining of
fossil fuels and I believe now there are
enormous externalities around turning
attention into Dollars specifically
through social media
and with fossil fuels we watch it happen
slowly and what do we know about it we
know there's externalities we know the
longer it takes to address the more
expensive it is to unwind
but with social media and technology and
search we've seen these externalities
like go up exponentially in just two
decades so I would argue it's it's the
super abundance that's the problem
because if you look at
if you look at there's some truth to a
middle class person right now in America
the UK lives a better life than the
wealthiest person a century ago
but there's so much abundance and so
much opportunity to communicate
abundance that nobody says well I should
be happy look at how our grandfather
lived and he was richer than us on a
relative basis all they think about is
Instagram's shoving this picture this
person all these people in my face all
day long and all I know about them is
they're hotter and richer than me
that's the Benchmark now dude status
status on our living conditions are
relative not absolute there was a study
done where they offered people the
choice between a uh
10 000 pound increase in the annual
salary
or a promotion to a newer more um
hierarchical job title
more people chose the job title than ten
thousand pounds a year simply because we
look to be we want relative status that
makes us feel good and I think that
you're right as well that it's all well
in good saying look at the material
abundance that we have now but it's very
quickly gone from scarcity to
overabundance hypernormal stimuli too
much food too much information think
about this there was a period I don't
know maybe the Autumn of 2011 or 2012 or
something like that when we had the
optimal balance between how much
information we wanted and how much
information we could access
for almost all of human history a tiny
tiny little bit more information was
maybe meant the difference between life
and death this winter because you knew
how to stitch a different sort of cloak
together that you and your family could
sleep under or you found a new Bush or a
way to hold the garden whatever it might
be
and then in at some point between 2005
and 2013 that switched and there was way
more information than we needed
I think the pivotal moment was when
social went on mobile
and that was all day long you had an
opportunity to get a quick dope ahead
and you get the dope ahead pulling your
phone out even before you see it to see
what kind of affirmation what kind of
love what kind of how do I how do I
[Music]
um
pair up how do I measure up versus
competitors what's happening to my my my
uh Dojo coin that day
is anyone swiped right on me
um can I go do I have an alert from
YouPorn on some weird fetish thing that
increasingly gets weirder and weirder
and it's in my it's in my pocket all day
long and what you see is in 2013 when
social went on mobile he saw
skyrocketing levels of depression and
self-harm and this isn't self-reporting
this is actual Hospital admissions
so the overabundance of information
constant stimuli
and then what you have is it's
especially appealing and especially
prevalent among people whose brains have
enough have developed enough to
appreciate it and need it and want
social structure you know shaming and
adulation and reaffirmation are
important part of the species it's
important that we value certain
affirmation it creates good behavior and
good role models
but when you don't have the capacity to
absorb the negative stuff or modulate it
which is exactly where teenagers are it
results in an America there's between
one and four thousand parents every
night who take their kid to the
emergency room
because they're scared to go to sleep
for fear what might happen
in what they might find in the morning
with their incredibly depressed 15 year
old girl so they just go they just take
the kid to the emergency room and the
emergency rooms around America don't
know what to do because they they're not
used to this problem yeah they don't
know how to they basically say we can
put them we can put them on suicide
watch we can submit them to the hospital
but we don't know what to do there's no
like immediate therapy or drug we can
even ssris aren't going to step in and
stop you from I mean what do you do take
the first time take the phone away
isolate them from all of the people the
only form of
one one question that I had in my head a
lot of the time people ask about what
would you do if you were in your 20s and
pieces of advice very rarely hear people
get asked about what you would do if you
were in your 30s so what advice would
you give to people that are in their 30s
are entering their 30s about how to
operate in life
I think it's really situational I don't
think there's a user's manual I think
there's some best practices and I don't
think it's that much different than in
your 20s
um the first is very Primal I think
every person in their 20s and 30s should
lift heavy weights and run long
distances in their brain and in the gym
push yourself really hard you're when
you're in your 20s and 30s you don't
even realize how old are you 34. okay so
like you look like a beast and in 20
years you're just going to look back on
how strong you were and just marvel at
it and you're going to wish as strong as
you were that you even push yourself
harder I rode crew it was such a
valuable part of my life I did at the
age of 19. and I remember in the midst
of a race it's a 2000 meter race
and I remember not being able to feel my
legs starting to black out and having to
concentrate on not blacking out from
exhaustion my and the the oxygen or the
air going down my esophagus was on fire
tastes like blood and metal in your
throat yeah and that was at 800 meters
and you'd go 2 000. and that ability
just when you think just when you think
you can't take any more
that means you're about a third of the
way to your limits as as a as a human as
a species learning that as a young man
or woman is a blessing because what it
means is you have the confidence that
when when things are hard physically
emotionally mentally you realize oh my
God I could take so much more and still
be fine and when I worked my first job
was a Morton Stanley at Investment Bank
and I was undereducated relative to my
peer group not because I didn't go to
Great school I went to UCLA but I spent
the majority of my five years there
making bongs out of household items and
watching Planet of the Apes so I wasn't
as skilled as my peer group so I decided
every Tuesday morning I was going to
come into work
and I wasn't going to leave till
Wednesday night
and I'm like I can do that I'm
physically really strong I'm mentally
really strong
and it sent a signal to the rest of the
organization that I came to play
develop that kind of grit and strength
emotionally physically and
intellectually in your 20s and 30s
you're capable of it you're just going
to look back on that era and be like
just marvel it out out of [ __ ]
control strong you are both mentally and
physically
2. get to a city if you can and that
sounds very practical or wrote but you'd
rather be good in a big city than great
in a small City before you collect dogs
and kids
you know being in a city is like playing
tennis with Roger Federer and Nadal when
you play with people much better than
you your game gets much better you're
playing against the best when you're in
a city
uh
find create as many opportunities to
find a mate now what do I mean by that
get out as often as possible accept
invitations force yourself to go out
force yourself to meet strangers develop
the skills
uh start whenever you're waiting in line
at Starbucks talk to the person in front
of you talk to the person behind you
develop the skills to begin opening and
establishing relationships and it's
uncomfortable and it means getting used
to rejection
and by the way the only thing I can
guarantee you in life
is rejection and the only thing I
guarantee a lot of if you want to be
successful is a [ __ ] ton of rejection
being an entrepreneur just means you're
willing to take out a big spoon and eat
[ __ ] all the time talking people into
working for you talking clients into to
to to engaging you talking investors
into investing and having 90 plus
percent of them saying no and the same
is true with successful mating the most
important decision you'll make in your
20s and 30s is where you live where you
work what industry you're going to it's
who you decide to partner with
specifically who you decide to
ultimately have kids with and I have
close friends who are monstrously
successful by every external metric and
they don't have great lives because they
don't have real Partners in their
spouses and I have other friends who
struggle economically and it's hard
but everything's a little easier for
them because they have a real partner
and the way you punch above your weight
class and find a great mate uh you know
emotionally intellectually from a value
standpoint sexually is you give yourself
as many opportunities as possible and my
story as I met uh my partner who I had
kids with the Raleigh Hotel at the pool
at the Raleigh Hotel in South Beach
about 17 years ago it was the middle of
the day and I walked in and I think it's
important to do this I walked in and I
saw someone I was really attracted to
and I said I'm going to talk to this
person before I leave and I promise
myself and I went up
in the full light of midday sun when she
was sitting with another guy and another
girl and opened and without the aid of
alcohol that is not easy that is not
easy and fast forward my oldest son's
middle name is Raleigh
if you nothing wonderful is going to
happen to you unless you take an
uncomfortable risk so get good at taking
them get good at sending blind emails to
LinkedIn contacts to ask them for coffee
to see if they'll talk to you about that
industry
reach out to people tell them you admire
them try and become friends with them
you know you're you're an interesting
guy I was just thinking myself I'd love
to know this guy does he live in London
he just seems very cool get comfortable
taking those sorts of risks get
comfortable with rejection nothing
wonderful will happen to you unless you
take an uncomfortable risk the most
important thing you can find in your
life in your 20s and 30s is something
that you're good at so that you can
start
building a base around Economic Security
but the the real key is to find a great
partner and that is going to be a
function of liquidity how many great
Partners potential great Partners you
approach and unfortunately
the far left of which I'm apart as tree
as counseled men that if you start
talking to a woman at work and you
express any sort of Interest it means
you're toxic no it doesn't if you don't
know the difference between expressing
interest and having coffee with someone
and harassing them you've got much
bigger problems a third of relationships
begin at work I'm not suggesting anyone
should ever abuse their power I'm I'm
not suggesting you shouldn't be very
careful that you're ever leveraging
power making anyone uncomfortable but
for God's sakes go up and talk to
strangers there's nothing wrong with
that and if you approach a strange woman
and and try and express get a
conversation going and she's not
interested you're both going to be fine
you're both gonna be fine and what I see
as a generation of men who don't take
care of themselves physically and become
so isolated that the idea of talking to
a strange woman is so alien and alien
and uncomfortable to them they just
rather stay home and do something else
and I don't want to stereotype all
introverts is is leading to bad places
that's not true at all but the majority
of men you talk to they want to be
financially successful and they want to
have a great partner at some point and
that is a function of of your
willingness to put yourself in
uncomfortable situation so anyways get
mentally and physically strong take
economic responsibility for your
household get out of the house as much
as possible try and find things where
you're building something in the agency
of others I don't care every day you
should be be around strangers every day
like if it's work I don't know if it's
church I don't care if it's non-profit a
softball league the gym classes whatever
it is you need to be around a massive
number of strangers and finding reasons
to have bump off of them and find
economic and personal and platonic
opportunities as often as possible we
are a social species to get to a city
get around a lot of people get out there
every day start making money and become
really strong you should be able to walk
into any room in your at your age and
think if [ __ ] got real I can kill and
eat everybody or outrun them one or the
other one or the other now I'm at the
point where I can do neither I'm not
strong and my knees are going but
anyways at your age it should be one or
both you could pay someone to kill
everybody or coming there you go that
would be awesome there you go yeah Scott
Galloway ladies and gentlemen uh dude I
appreciate the [ __ ] out of you this is
really really interesting I've been
looking forward to speaking to you for a
while if people want to harass you
online and find all of your stuff where
should they go
yeah to resist this feudal I'm
everywhere uh
Prof Galloway on Twitter
profgalway.com and just uh and my new
book adrift American 100 charts
available on let me think Amazon let's
go Scott thank you thank you thanks for
your good work and congrats on all your
success what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]